It is time to play
The Symptoms. The Symptoms.
-CHORUS: ♪ The Symptoms
-WOMAN: (coughs)
-Yeah.
-Very nice.
Who needs a doctor to tell you
that a zit on your back
is cancer when Google
will do that for you?
Just type in your symptoms
and good old Goog
will provide a soothing
watercolor
of rare, exotic diseases
that you wish you had,
but probably don't have.
You're probably okay.
So comedians, I'm gonna show you
a Google illustration
of some sick sickies
and their symptoms
and for 250 points I want you
to tell me what they have.
All right, first up, this one...
looks a little swollen.
I don't know what that is.
What is that?
Uh, Shelby.
Oh, she used to be
so cute syndrome.
Points.
Points. Blaine.
Well, obviously, Chris, this
young girl filled up on glands.
-All right, points.
-I'm... Chris, Chris,
I'm-I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
Uh, this child
-has terminal mom haircut.
-All right, points.
Points.
-Terminal?
-She does.
Uh, Patton.
Chipotle cheek.
All right, points to Patton.
Next one, this one...
Well, this looks fun.
Patton.
Cancer of the snuggles.
-Oh...
-It's incurable.
He's got a little cancer
to snuggle!
If your snuggle
lasts more than four hours...
-That is... Oh, you...
-Points. Shelby.
Aw, he's got a bad case of the
first ten minutes of Up, Chris.
-Yeah, all right, points.
OSWALT: Oh...
-No, you don't.
-Yes!
-And she does.
-All right, next one.
Next one.
This one looks uncomfortable.
Uh, Patton.
Early onset Ted Cruz.
That's not curable.
I don't think that's curable.
-It's really... Poor kid.
-Yeah, you're right.
You're right.
It-it spreads easily.
-It, uh, really does.
-Yeah.
At least that's
what your mother said.
-Yeah!
-(exclaiming)
Oh, snap!
HARDWICK:
Damn.
My mom will totally (bleep) you
by the way. I don't know if...
-Oh, okay.
-All right.
Well then, good-bye. I...
(whooping, applause)
The... Sorry, the joke was
that I left to (bleep) your mom.
No, the joke was
that you did it that fast.
-Oh... Mm...
-Oh.
Blaine.
Well, Chris, I don't know
about these kids,
but it looks like their father
has explosive diarrhea.
FERO:
He's just smiling through it.
I'm kidding, Chris.
They have leukemia.